>> Tucker: EXACTLY ONE YEAR AGO
TONIGHT, BUZZ FEED RELEASED THE
TRUMP DOSSIER TO THE PUBLIC EVEN
WERE SCANDALOUS AND SALACIOUS.
WE BLASTED THEM AT THE TIME.
NOW THEY'RE GETTING SUED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY,
MICHAEL COHEN, SUED BUZZ FEED
AND DOSSIER CREATOR FUSION GPS,
THE FIRM, SAYING THE DOCUMENT
DEFAMES THE PRESIDENT BY
BASELESSLY LINKING HIM TO RUSSIA
THE DOSSIER'S RELEASE A YEAR AGO
AND IS GAME ENOUGH TO JOIN US
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE?
>> VERY MUCH WHAT I TOLD YOU
LAST YEAR.
THE DOSSIER IS A DOCUMENT OF
KIND OF OBVIOUS CENTRAL PUBLIC
IMPORTANCE.
IT'S THE SUBJECT OF MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS BY INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES, BY CONGRESS.
THAT WAS CLEAR A YEAR AGO.
IT'S A LOT CLEARER NOW.
BEFORE WE PUBLISHED IT, AS WE
KNEW THEN.
IMPORTANT ELECTED OFFICIALS,
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES WERE
INVESTIGATING THIS DOCUMENT.
WHEN WE TALKED LAST TIME, THAT
WAS A SUBJECT OF SOME DISPUTE.
LOT OF PEOPLE, I'M NOT SURE IF
NONSENSE DOCUMENT.
NOW WHAT I SEE ON FOX NEWS IN
PARTICULAR IS THAT THIS DOCUMENT
WAS CENTRAL ARGUABLY TOO CENTRAL
TO THE FBI INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THINGS THAT WE KNOW.
THERE'S A LOT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT ITS ROLE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION BUT IT SURE SEEMS
LIKE THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A
LONG TIME.
YOU KNOW ALL KINDS OF
INEFFECTIVE DOSSIERS COME ACROSS
THE DESK OF INVESTIGATOR, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND PEOPLE
COVER THEM AND THEY'RE NOT MADE
PUBLIC BECAUSE THEIR CONTENTS
ARE UNVERIFIED, SOMETIMES
UNVERIFIABLE AND THEY'RE
DEFAMATORY.
SO YOU SEE A LOT OF STUFF THAT
YOU DON'T PASS ON BECAUSE YOU
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S TRUE.
THE WORDS HANG IN THE AIR.
YOU LIBEL SOMEONE N EFFECT.
SO YOU DON'T RUN IT.
BUT YOU DID RUN THIS BECAUSE IT
WAS TRUMP.
>> YOUR IN BOX AND MINE, AS YOU
SAY, ARE FULL OF TIPS OF
ALLEGATIONS OF CRIMES.
THEY ARE NOT FULL OF DOCUMENTS
TO THE PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS.
FOR INSTANCE, IMAGINE COVERING
THE WEEK THAT WE JUST HAD,
TO THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
THE BATTLE BETWEEN FEINSTEIN AND
GRASSLEY IN A SITUATION WHICH
AMERICANS WOULD HAVE A LOT OF
TROUBLE UNDERSTANDING FOR THE
LAST YEAR WITHOUT THIS DOCUMENT.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
BUT YOU'RE MAKING A RETROACTIVE
ARGUMENT.
THAT WAS PULLING HARRY REID --
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE POINT.
WE NOW HAVE THE CONTEXT FOR IT.
WE DIDN'T THEN.
>> LOT OF US DID.
>> Tucker: IT WASN'T -- I DIDN'T
READ IT ON BUZZFEED.
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS WAS PART OF
THE HILLARY CLINTON OPERATION
THAT SHE TOOK UP FROM AN
ANTI-TRUMP REPUBLICAN DONOR
OPERATION.
SOURCES.
>> THE CHARACTERIZATION OF FIELD
SOURCES ARE IN THE DOSSIER.
IT'S TRUE, THERE'S BEEN A TON OF
SUBSEQUENT REPORTING.
>> Tucker: HERE'S THE POINTED.
YOU'RE ARGUING IT'S THE CENTER
OF THE NEWS SO WE ARE RIGHT TO
RUN IT.
I'M NOT ATTACKING YOU FOR
WE WERE IN THE EXACT SAME
SITUATION WITH PRESIDENT
CLINTON, WITH WOULD HAVE RUN
THAT.
I CAN DO THAT TO YOU.
FOR INSTANCE, THERE WAS A DAY
LAST YEAR, IT WAS NOT THE
BIGGEST STORY OF THE DAY BECAUSE
IT WAS THE DAY OF THE ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD TAPE, BUT ALSO ON THAT
DAY, WE WERE THE FIRST TO REPORT
ON THE SUBSTANCE OF HILLARY
I THINK THERE'S THIS PERCEPTION
--
>> Tucker: THIS IS DIFFERENT
LEVEL SALACIOUS.
>> NO ONE WAS INTERESTED IN THEM
ONCE THEY CAME OUT.
>> Tucker: I WAS INTERESTED BUT
THEY WEREN'T CLAIMING THAT SHE
>> Tucker: WE HAVE ACTUALLY.
WE HAVE.
THERE WAS A LOT OF STUFF
FLOATING AROUND ABOUT OBAMA AND
HIS PERSONAL LIFE, THE QUESTION
OF WHERE HE WAS BORN.
WE SORT OF LAUGH ABOUT IT.
NOW THERE'S A BIG NEWS STORY
PEOPLE MAKING ALLEGATIONS ABOUT
IT, INCLUDING NOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IF YOU CAME ACROSS A DOSSIER
THAT LAID OUT THAT HE WAS BORN
IN KENYA, HAD A WEIRD PERSON,
YOU WOULD BE ATTACKED BY
THE PRESIDENT, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: IF IT WAS A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
IF TRUMP WERE PRESIDENT --
>> DONALD TRUMP MADE THESE
RIDICULOUS CLAIMS ABOUT THE
BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
WE COVERED THEM.
WE DIDN'T BLEEP THEM OUT.
>> Tucker: IF THERE WAS A
DETAILED DOSSIER ON THE SUBJECT
THAT HAD BEEN ASSEMBLED --
>> UNFORTUNATELY THE DOSSIER WAS
HIS -- HE WAS SMART ENOUGH TO
PUT ALL THAT STUFF IN A DOSSIER
HE PUBLISHED IN HIS MEMOIR IN
OBAMA'S CASE.
>> Tucker: LOOK, THE TRUTH IS,
THIS STUFF WAS UNVERIFIED A YEAR
AGOP IT REMAINS UNVERIFIED.
>> SOME ELEMENTS OF IT HAVE BEEN
CORROBORATED.
>> Tucker: THE BIG STUFF HAS NOT
BEEN.
THERE'S STILL NO EVIDENCE --
>> I THINK MANAFORT INDICTMENT
IS PRETTY BIG STUFF.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NO CLOSER TO
PROVING THAT HE COLLABORATED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT OR
THAT'S CHARACTER ASSASSINATION
AND STILL UNPROVEN.
>> THAT IS UNPROVEN.
>> Tucker: YEAH, OKAY.
>> THE BROAD OUTLINE OF THE
RUSSIAN CAMPAIGN PENETRATING THE
AMERICAN ELECTION I THINK HAS